hey gang real quick before we get the
old show started let's talk about these
live days we got coming up
it's the keep it moving 2021 tour
and we're coming to a town near you
we're going to be
in atlantic city new jersey june 18th oh
yeah and then we're gonna be in chicago
for our fourth and final show on june
22nd
then we're heading over to indianapolis
indiana
at the helium over there on june 23rd
get some tickets
and then we're coming back thursday
night back to the windy city
for two sold out shows so if you heard a
date on there
that wasn't sold out buy some tickets
and come see us
it's gonna be a great time yeah guys the
live show's awesome it's stand up and
then we play ayg
with the audience we answer your
questions it's a good [ __ ] time get
involved
see you there oh baby welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
r.u garbage it sure is baby it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy
or just a big old piece of trash yep i'm
your host age foley coming at you on a
beautiful
day down here in aunt toddy's basement
she's up to her old tricks again
yeah dog medication really yeah she's
boofing it
selling it selling it yeah i gotta get
cats or bitcoin she's into crypto and
sleepies
uh my co-host is coming at you i
got this guy's thing sleepy
i was thinking dog trying special k or
something gang he's the ceo of argue
garbage he's international businessman
he's not to be taken lightly in the
boardroom
and in negotiations
i'm a beast in the boardroom and a bull
in the bedroom he's a stiff negotiator i
just found out the hard way
this guy's got me upside down in a vfw
show in a couple of months
that's so funny i can't walk away i
already took the deposit
and i ain't got it yeah give it up for
kevin james ryan come on now
hey gang happy to be here thanks for
tuning in
as always oh yeah please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes be nice
uh we're we're we're constantly at top 1
200
we're in the top of the charts which i
love if you're into this and you haven't
dropped a review go drop a [ __ ]
review that helps us out in the charts
uh and then youtube.com full hd video
available there three camera shoot we're
doing
hd quality hd quality and as you know
those numbers are
true to roof roof right right i concur
with the gentleman
north carolina and then patreon.com baby
those numbers
are cooking come on patreon.com are you
garbage you get bonus episodes at ayg
the people are they're never coming out
on the free feed they just live on
patreon.com some people gotta hit me up
like yeah you know
they just stay on patreon.com so you
sign up there you get [ __ ]
from when we started back in november or
something you get
all the backlog of all the episodes of
hard feelings ayg
we do a live stream with the top tier uh
members every month which is a good
[ __ ] time there's a library
i call it a catalog catalog you sign up
today for five bucks you get all the
ayg's from the past [ __ ]
six months or whatever sure or you play
the smart money you drop a ten ski
you get the hard feeling that's the
smart play we have more ten dollar
members than five dollar members because
our people are after value you know what
i mean they're not
you know they're not they're looking for
more bang for their buck i feel like
we're on qvc right now
only three memberships remaining it's
the toby put a number and it just drops
it
i like it um yeah gang so check it out
yes check it out and how about a nice
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up
dudes
yo t-bone notice that foley no longer
says pride of chicago comedy scene after
meeting some of my friends from chicago
well i can't say you're the pride of
chicago comedy scene because you're no
longer
on the chicago comedy scene as of june
1st okay t-bone lives in queens
new york city comedian wow
huh comedian's debatable i haven't seen
it yet but call up
new yorker call up ma t-bone down there
in north carolina tell her [ __ ] your
kid
your sons made it yeah i got a shitty
little apartment me and my kitty cat
thin walls good for the neighbors
hearing me cry yeah
i like a good cry from noon to one every
day
cat scratching trying to get away from
you happy happy for you too
happy for you t-bone settled in [ __ ]
queens new york
my [ __ ] next door neighbor yeah how
close are you guys
we're real close real close
i could be there walking in 15 minutes
so it's probably two blocks
just the next apartment over as long as
there's not a mcdonald's i could be
there in 15 minutes oh
let's not talk about mcdonald's oh god
stuff's all behind me the weight off by
the way i'm sure
they'll check out the weight loss
challenge that their patreon over there
i'm off the junk baby i'm clean
good happy to hear oh my god speaking of
junk walk it over
dude fully booting up right on our block
yeah it's a time oh here in the city
tough neighborhood oh they're partying
down here yeah they're getting where we
are
they're getting manhattan's [ __ ]
right put it day drinking with arm beers
wow
heroin referred as arm beers i'm a fan
everybody knows a good nose beer from
time to time a couple of armed beers
maybe a tow beer
or in between your toe beers when your
parents are hassling you yeah
i don't want to see any tracks did i
ever tell you that my buddy
uh buddy's family had a i'm sure i
mentioned it maybe at some point my
buddy's family had a party
like parents only and he had this
[ __ ]
so he show up and he his family dealt
with some nefarious characters
right they were real new money and we
went over the next day my parents had
gone over there for like 20 minutes and
they were like yo we're
we're getting the [ __ ] out this ain't
our scene and uh
we saw we found a spoon the next day
with in the bathroom with like yellow
residue on it i was like these
dudes [ __ ] party love jell-o pudding
somebody forgot their yogurt
yeah i was like yay karamba you know
what's always embarrassing when you're
going to the ice cream so hard that it
bends the spoon that's a real [ __ ]
what happened to uncle ted he got a hot
shot of fruit though
at this barbecue for 50 year olds a
little too much
little too much euro tart for uncle ted
huh
could have couldn't handle the berries
at the bottom
holy [ __ ] yeah that's trash yeah i
remember that was a sign i was just like
we're different
i'm trash i'm like we're different
people we come from different cloths
you don't shoot heroin my family doesn't
associate with known drug addicts in
their 50s
ah man i had a we had a little
get-together this weekend at the
foley's little uh little club foley down
there club foley
yeah problem is eating his heated isn't
a bluebell
[ __ ] swinger party with a bunch of
oxen
all right when you see the red light on
the porch come on
in back make sure you walk in backwards
though
i think you don't like it i don't know
make it a little more kinky
you know what i mean let you know what
you're working with flip-flops and
blown-out couches as far as
i can see i have recliners that don't
close
that's where it gets weird all the
springs are [ __ ] shot out
ah no club foley was only half opened
and it was a disappointment to the crowd
how was it only half phone no pool what
yeah all that patreon money flying
around those bozos couldn't know the
motor went
your pool has a motor what is this what
a [ __ ] john deere
your pool's got a motor yeah every pool
has a motor how do you think the water
gets circulated in there
a pump whatever it's not a mobile motor
is different i did i
then it's emotional no one's ever been
like hey start this puppy
up the gentlemen start your engines we
gotta get the pool cooking it's memorial
day
you gotta prime it before you get in the
deep end you put
did you did you do the right mix of gas
and oil
it's electric boogie woogie woogie
you can't be but um yeah the motor
didn't run
motoring uh
so it's coming in this week so we're a
week behind but that
motor still people there with a [ __ ]
with a couple hot dogs and some sweat on
their bro and not even hot dogs
a non-open up above ground pool barbecue
yeah i would have rather had it okay
let's go look at the pool again
what i'd rather have in a walmart
parking lot that's a tough look
and let me tell you something the whole
time you're eating and hanging out
you're about 20
20 steps away from pure death because
there's enough shock and chlorine in
that pool
the [ __ ] you guys are all [ __ ]
high as that guy you make dr manhattan
in there
oh damn tough that's a sad
sad you also sent me a picture of a
makeshift
umbrella you robbed a hang glider
that thing was [ __ ] heavy duty but
you know how you can
you know uh the
umbrella's supposed to go in through the
table which yours didn't it didn't fit
so it was a different
heavy duty it's a heavy-duty umbrella so
it's a different
umbrella so it's an aftermarket umbrella
you got
yes where'd you that was a discount buy
i had to be amazon prime
this thing's rough yeah should we sit in
a big blue hawaiian
oh it's real trashy so
okay and it didn't fit in the table she
had it next to the table so i came up
with the idea how about we do this
because it's bad when you're the [ __ ]
head engineer on the job site
at least you want it plus she's okay let
me do a couple of arm beers and i'll
figure this out
she skipped about three or four of the
safety steps i don't need osha poking
around in there let me that thing didn't
come with instructions that was that box
that was an open box purchase now that's
four drywall screws straight to the
dagger here
oh man um so we couldn't get it to go
above so
my dad likes to go in there in the
evenings watch the phillies game and do
his little exercises and stuff like that
what's in where
he likes to go in the pool okay goes in
the pool watching so it hangs so you
have an umbrella that
i saw you bump the table right up next
to the pool yeah so we got it where it
covers a little bit of the pool so you
can hang out
you can hang out in the pool on the
thing while everyone's talking you're
watching the fills
and then also one half of the table is
is also shaded too
now but on the other side of that table
on a hot day
let me tell you it hurts i don't have
the webster dictionary for
white trash but i'm pretty sure you
checked a couple of the boxes there big
man
is there an ext where's the tv that
you're watching it's it hangs on
we we bring it inside in the in the
winter because it'll crack the screen
it's up in my room we bring it down and
we hang it watch philly's games
hang it on what we have a [ __ ] like a
thing like this is there an extension
cord
a thing like that's all like ours like
an arm that comes out it says it's all
act like i'm giving you [ __ ] you just
said you're making you got an umbrella
hanging over your pool and a picnic
table
all of a sudden i ask one question on
the electronic aspect of it and you're
you're acting like i'm i'm the jerk off
bam
yeah we hang that up so good for you
that's good rough
yeah gotta almost got a little rougher
too if i don't mind telling you
gentlemen
and why well you know i had some uh
let's say counting errors towards the
end of the month i
i saw a screenshot of said bank
statement over there at navy federal and
i gotta tell you
it was [ __ ] red lights [ __ ] all
the way down the avenue
man [ __ ] hollywood chewed me up and
spit me out
[ __ ] right back to zero no it was uh
you weren't even at zero
dude yeah you were on those negative
four digits
so we were waiting on a couple of things
we were getting jerked around by a
couple of suppliers
yeah um so they didn't make the [ __ ]
payment
so i had this all mapped out this is my
master i was i this was hopefully
my last my last month of spinning plates
this was going to be the weekend this
this was it i was like i was going to
change my name to the weekend
that's how pumped i was for this weekend
and then
you just said weekend like 15 times in a
sentence we got them like gearing up for
memorial day thinking you're going to
costco and then showing up at the aldi
oh
dude i was it was well that's what
happened to me i was jammed up
oh i was jammed up and those rugrats
down there
i might have had to take a personal
personal marker out from uh
from said foreign investor i had a sign
over personally on a couple of things
and a bald guy's here with his nose wide
open man
i uh so okay so i woke up saturday
morning
and hawaiian cartoons after my cartoons
and my
my cereal um i looked at my bank account
hawaiian airlines had gotten cheeky and
[ __ ]
charged me twice for something which i
don't get it there's not enough in the
checking account
why does the bank let it go through just
reject it no
[ __ ] navy federal it's like they're
working together they [ __ ] put me in
a hole now i'm upside down on my own
checking account
so you're upside down in the house
so i get on the phone i start talking to
[ __ ] uh hawaiian airlines start
working and that's about an hour process
i do this while i'm driving down
sure okay do you speak hawaiian no okay
before i get
before i get in the car though it wasn't
that good i'm sorry
i don't know he answered me like [ __ ]
like you were in a [ __ ] deposition
no i don't not anymore i mean i could
order a restaurant but
i'm not fluent i could hurt
so i had a couple of bucks in my
savings had about 150 in there clean
so before anybody starts getting you're
the only two person two percent on that
annually that's like three four dollars
you're the only person i ever heard
referred to is 150 as clean yeah i own
that straight out i don't i want 50 is
mine
there's no note on that that's me that's
in my that's all that's what
that's all meat baby that's all that's
all i see
so i didn't want food you got 150 and
you're in your savings account
a lot of times a lot of times you got to
read the [ __ ] fine print on those
savings
i mean we're just in between a couple of
paydays you know i mean i got hemmed up
i got jammed up but a lot of times in
them savings account you gotta
[ __ ] you gotta keep like uh at least
a hundo in there oh no
maybe you leave your keys in there maybe
they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care take your money
as far as we know it belongs to you
anyway take what's yours
no you know right now i got i got zeros
right
i got snake eyes right
[Laughter]
so yeah i had to take out two markers
this weekend
for me alone i was like hey i need this
just to get by
and then i get a couple of bucks i start
spending time we stink the money i'm
taking ubers again thank god we learned
this a little less well i see that
patreon number
i also clean things up by the end of the
month and then they do
they first of all patreon what's their
beat man you start [ __ ] unpacking
that thing it's like a russian nesting
doll
yeah fees and overhead plus tony needs
that you got to pay to rent on hoodie
you got to keep [ __ ] a roof over
teddy's head
jesus those dog pills ain't going to
[ __ ] save us no money more problems
as biggie said
toby's like hey if you need a couple of
bucks to get to the weekend i should be
lending you money
i know toby mcmullen the richest man i
know
meanwhile i had to make it make a fake
[ __ ] letter of employment for this
guy
oh yeah i'm like yeah he makes a hundred
and eighty seven thousand dollars a year
give him the apartment bozo
yeah a little a little life tip for you
for anyone listening
work for your friend because they could
laugh it was pretty funny you want like
i mean
this is where i shot i know toby's like
hey listen would you be okay with like
maybe
you know saying i make a little bit more
than i actually do i've been i'm like
i'm like i'll go one step further you
venmo me money i'll deposit him to
totties and make it look like paychecks
he goes
oh that's pretty good i got buddy
welcome to the deep end because that's
where i
that's where i maneuver i've i've been
the assistant regional manager of
many a restaurant for my friends by the
way
uh the landlord was like so i was
looking into the
teddy llc do you guys make desks
and i was like yeah that's what we do
that's how much cash you got on you i
believe the correct the direct quote was
we do a little bit of everything
we got our hands in a lot of pots you
know we're a venture venture capitalist
firm
you ever have oat milk before yeah i
have i signed here i signed it
by the way president and ceo h
ah schmoly well the first thing i heard
you're answering a dead man's phone
yeah try to try to trace that letter
back it's just ringing at the bottom of
the hudson
bubble
i put a fake number the address wasn't
[ __ ]
you're in there now and that's all it
man can't do anything when you got the
keys it's real hard to get to get
squatters out of there yeah
so thank god that worked out wait you
seen ain't got to pay
the way this is going you're not going
to have money to pay
no we're doing great everybody so
i didn't want just very bad with money i
didn't want navy federal
[ __ ] coming in and [ __ ] swooping
in [ __ ] cleaning house because they
what they'll do is
if if the checking is negative for too
long they'll [ __ ] yank it from
from uh the savings stealing from peter
to pay for fatty
so i grabbed that quick 150 and i used
to have a little cash in my hand would
you go to the atm
went right to the atm like nope yeah
[ __ ] yank that right out shh foley's
banking in international waters there
ain't no rules out there dude i had to
put a couple of bucks
in the car get some [ __ ] gas couple
of odds and ends
almost get jammed up all right i got
enough gas to [ __ ] get me out of
there
all right [ __ ] sitting on a couple of
shekels in my pocket
now there's no pool so the kids are a
little bummed out
you know what i mean spring with the
hose call it a night i offered that they
didn't wanna
set up a chair i'll sit down i'll spray
with a hose give me a couple of pops
they didn't wanna do it um but then all
of a sudden
we hear a familiar tune coming through
the trees in the neighborhood
who is it ice cream man the ice cream
man
now we're all out like that foley's back
to zero
i've been running my mouth down there
about how good we're doing
okay yeah you got about what 30 40 clams
on you
listen i'm sitting there okay the wallet
was put away
one night this is more of a hard
feelings but okay we got to get into
questions
yeah um yeah everything you do is fresh
i mean like you could have just said
what you did yesterday and what it would
have been a trashy story well i'm
sitting there the ice cream man starts
ringing for some reason
everyone starts saying oh they're
screaming oh that's a great that's a
great job for uncle hank that's an uncle
thing uncle hank
uncle hank give him money to get to go
get the ice cream
[ __ ] i tell my nephew to go get my
wallet pulls out
my last 20. you only got 120 on you
man all right and they take off down the
street
pick something from the bottom and let
me just play the bottom
don't ever underestimate or don't ever
don't ever look down upon poor genetics
cause i guess these kids couldn't catch
the ice cream man
and they came back joke's on you little
fatties
they came back with the 20. yeah we
lived a fight another day yeah
finished my grilled chicken and i said
good night to everyone like a gentleman
oh
man but that's neither here nor there of
course this is a family episode
of course yeah you know yeah i'm just
saying save some meat on the bone we
gotta we gotta do a hard feelings as
well this that's
prime hard feelings going toe-to-toe
with financial institution that's what
hard feelings started about three years
ago
[ __ ] toe-to-toe with big banks oh i
just felt pretty garbage only having 20
bucks in there
yeah needing the ice cream money back
from my thank god he doesn't take
[ __ ] credit cards but i only got 20
on me i only got 20 on me
i couldn't have said that i would have
been they would have known something was
up
what if you only had 20 on you yeah hey
man i got 20 on me
did i take a car i should have said i
had no things does
take me take a card right what if they
did then you're
really headed up you have no idea those
kids would be facing some charge good
humor hit the gas will you
yeah my credit card was just stolen yeah
i can describe all of them yeah there's
three of them they're in my front yard
right now
sucking down choco tacos i only
authorized
i only authorized the firecracker pop
but that was for me i got the detectives
here now
oh god all right guys all right uh as
you know this is a [ __ ] family
episode we answer your [ __ ] garbage
questions
uh so when you sign up for the patreon
we'll answer your garbage question and
we
got some heaters we got some heaters we
always do
fun stuff i think we got the funniest
listeners out there too some of them
they're [ __ ]
they know how to write a [ __ ] garbage
question i'll tell you that much you're
good people
um let's see you know what they say
you gotta write what you know you gotta
write what you done these we're starting
you said i think like two episodes ago i
think the last family episode
you were like i think we're just
starting to scratch the surface on some
levels of garbage
that okay we're not like you know super
me and you aren't accustomed to you know
there's there's obviously a deeper
darker world than what
than the worlds i operate in a gentleman
to a degree
of course um this one is just a
[ __ ] home run funny uh this is from
gibson
ever play with a foam nerf football with
a human bite taken out of it
buddy for some reason nerf just wanted
you to [ __ ]
that was like why was that thing looked
like a [ __ ] whopper dude that was
good eating
yeah just take a [ __ ] i would always
put teeth
right on the corner for some reason that
and getting them wet
getting them wet you were like
fascinating and then wringing out the
water
yeah taking that thing under water
be like a brick i felt like flipper oh
that thing would drown a baby
down there defusing a bomb or whatever
he did
saving the day holy [ __ ] that's
derf was [ __ ] nerf come on a-okay
but you were still your generation was
still solid nerfed because you
you guys had my [ __ ] you know me
alone what am i a [ __ ] joke you guys
started to have those things that look
like mortars the missiles
the vortex what was that i think that
might have been nerf originally as well
nerve vortex yeah wait if i can hurt
somebody
not the one with just the spinnies on it
i know that one the the orange and blue
one
i'm talking about no it had the tail
yeah yeah
it was like a bottle rocket yeah that
thing had a whistler tip on it too
yeah how much help did you guys needs i
have a glass of milk
in fact in that commercial they had the
[ __ ] i forget who it was
it was some uh it was some quarterback
and he threw it like
dude he literally threw it out of the
stadium like over the [ __ ]
over the nose please yeah those things
cooked he's stung dude you got a big
sixth grader with one of them he could
[ __ ] throw it three yards down if he
wanted to
they hurt really bad as well oh yeah
one of those [ __ ] right in the ear
[Laughter]
it's like you're getting shot going over
the wall
i grew up on the whistler tip and it was
a harsh awakening when i first played
with a real football
oh yeah
what's going on a couple of susie's
flying around
yeah it looks like you're throwing
left-handed
excuse me sure would there be apple
slices
uh can i get a can i get a football with
a tail on it please
this isn't regulation uh the original
nerf was a tough look those things
didn't last they got ripped up
[ __ ] up oh yeah the dog got a piece of
it yeah
[ __ ] now he was [ __ ] out nerf
[ __ ] colors ah my dog ate dental
floss one time
it's still coming out dude that was like
the magician pulling the ribbon out of
it we were sitting there looking
sitting there [ __ ] what was he doing
in the medicine cabinet
[Laughter]
looking for perks
there's there's if the foley's have a
dog he's looking for painkillers
rooting through size how these are old i
did find i did find
a bottle of cbd for dogs at my parents
house
what's the old man getting into
trying to keep her quiet
no she went to the trash it was cinnamon
cinnamon
dental floss and it was just hanging out
of her butt my mom just went
yo i just my butt just puckered when you
did that dude
like the natural reactions
[ __ ] anal beats without that like a
gerbil tail
yeah that i don't know my dog got a hold
of the crayons before
man it was like a [ __ ] basket it was
like a [ __ ] fish concert dude it
was [ __ ] tie-dye [ __ ] all over the
neighborhood
big grateful dead fan
i didn't know rusty was a deadhead
guys we're having fun i mean this is
what
little good times
oh man
excuse us pardon me uh where were we
this one i don't know i thought this was
classy i knew a guy that had this
and they were the epitome clash shout
out to dougie he's a listener and a
patreon
um his dad his he had it ever this is
from frank
ever make your own golf hole in your
yard
which i feel would be classy no it
depends
what are we talking about the astro turf
no
now the the one the guy i knew that
you're talking about going out and
getting this specific kind of grass for
greens and having like somebody like
level it and make it nice yeah
i don't know if you had [ __ ] kentucky
bluegrass or if he just set the john
deere to the lowest setting and gave him
seeds from st andrews yeah he [ __ ]
it was good though he had to pin the cup
and like
they kept it real tight real low it
wasn't and they would chip and like you
know putt i guess
sure it was the same guy who we went
over to see the [ __ ] ceramic
stove ah he worked for whirlpool oh so
he i had a little bit of cash he was an
executive he was an executive
yeah then that's cool he did it right
yeah yeah that's classy
yeah yeah most my dad ever had was like
that little golf thing that you put on
your desk where you just
where you watching or like it's like a
little tiny one like you ever see like
the little pools
like the little tiny pool tables that
you have you put on your desk
that was the kind of [ __ ] we were
talking about real big spenders over
there
nothing like that in the backyard you
know what i think trashy too
the the long strip with the ramp
the astro turf garbage yeah i never got
that
and i've tried myself from time to time
i'm starting to like it a lot i'll tell
you what
i was until i lost all my money but i'll
tell you this
the video games where you hit it into
the screen that's pretty trashy too like
a topgolf type thing no the things you
can like you hang the thing in your
garage yeah i think that's pretty nice
though is it
either no i don't toby shaking his head
no i'm also not looking to you
for what's classy when it comes to golf
though toby true i guarantee you i can
hit a ball farther than anyone in this
room
who said anything about that so that's
also 100 false
what's what's 100 i got a sweet stroke
dude it's as do i
i got for a very long time i didn't and
i will and i will embarrass you
this guy's guys yeah who's coming to
this
we got cameras also shout out to the
people we got uh a lot of people hit us
up for a dirt track no [ __ ]
really at least like six people hit us
up yo come out another guy hit us up
he's friends with the family that owns
graveyard oh yeah that's right
yeah he said i'm pretty sure i can get
him he goes i'm pretty sure i can get
you in there
he goes i know the guy there's one
parked across there's one in the park
across the street from me
i bowl with them or whatever yeah but
there's dude i mean people in like ohio
i wouldn't imagine grieving they were
like we don't i own a dirt track come
[ __ ] you know you can drive
whatever i don't know what's happening
we're in
get a cooler some hot dogs [ __ ] head
out there's also a demolition derby
npa coming up i think like july 10th or
something
let's go like truckzilla let's do it
eats a car or something as flames come
out of his eyes
i'm gonna put this out here what do you
got we are cooking on something that's
gonna be sick
and it's gonna involve a lot of footage
of traveling so if you have
if we're coming to your city yeah and
you have any sort of dope activity
that you would think we would enjoy hit
us the [ __ ] yeah
that includes chicago june 22nd still
some tickets left for the late show
uh indeed june 23rd those tickets are
[ __ ]
moving not really uh
and then atlantic city i by the time
this comes out it might be sold out
there's about 15 tickets left in the
lane do it
sell out ac come on go get those [ __ ]
tickets we can hit a bubba
bonus yeah a couple of bucks pockets you
know what i mean
plus i'm going to be hanging out
afterwards couple of pops
in the in the in the in the casino hell
i got i got a bar that i like to go to
down there oh that's right yeah
real baldies real real old schools would
you would you go
skydiving absolutely not no what
well i wasn't asking you they would have
to use some sort of you in
parachutes that they used to drop
supplies on [ __ ] africans
because of my weight no because of your
aerodynamics yeah your great head of
hair i want to mess up to do huh
let's see how this weight loss challenge
goes maybe he'll be down to 220. yeah
what about him he's got to be oh we're
not going
skydiving yeah you got a jet skiing you
got to be like 215 or something
215. yeah [ __ ] i'll be up 10 grand by
the end
that's the case um i would say if you
got a hole if you gotta if you got a
golf hole
in your yard it's got to be done right
that's the thing you can go
south quick that's the problem with a
lot of stuff that you do around the
house like
it's the upkeep you let it go you let it
go
then it looks bad bad not good a swing
set not put together a gazebo that's
half done yeah
well that's just maintenance yeah pump
yeah pump
um we had a [ __ ] we had an incomplete
shed
for a decade and then my mom finally
just got it removed and
planted trees or something they got that
guy living in a backyard
there's a whole thing you do have a guy
living i know there's a whole thing
yeah so it's not directly in our bed so
there's this guy who's it's not not
directly in your backyard
it's one it's not at the bus station no
it's behind you
to the left back into the left
it's a nice car though is it like a bmw
i don't know what he's got going on so
he was living in his house so his dad
his dad owns two houses down
that's weird too right and then so is
his dad owns
two houses you own more than one house
in your neighborhood but then there's
some plot
there's an empty plot of land he only
that's even weirder he owns a house
a lot the dad threw him out he's like
50.
he's not like the dad's like a hundred
something
i asked mama what's that guy doing [ __ ]
my mom's like i don't know they're like
trying to get
because it's a very upscale
township they're trying to like hey he
can't be just [ __ ] lit it's a thing
i was gonna ask you everybody's raising
the fences around them he's like living
in the penitentiary
dude everybody's putting up barrier
trees biting them in there yeah they're
boxing them in
real good i don't know what's going on
he was he lived in the house i think
he's like drinks or something i don't
[ __ ] you think
i don't think he's working but he's not
even uploading the new york times
crossword puzzle i can tell you that a
couple of cars
all right so we just put up a bunch of
trees to block them out
that's trashy man that's yeah our
neighbor raised his fence
like two feet i just imagine him like
hammering the nails just so the guy
couldn't see him anymore like that
as he put the last piece of what i'll
see you later timmy do you think that
there's like a pizza box up there yeah
starts running out of wood
um well you know no matter what no
matter how nice your house is
that's bringing you down there's nobody
living in their car
in my neighborhood yeah i i understand
my ma it's like they're trying
but it's also like they're being
compassionate it's like they don't want
to [ __ ]
uh they don't want to kick the guy he's
got nowhere to go
i don't [ __ ] got a house right there
they've called like the zoning board but
the dad won't let them in so they've
called the zoning board they're trying
to
like it's like what are they gonna
[ __ ] arrest the guy i don't know
what's going on i stay out of it i just
know we're [ __ ]
we're building the redwood forest to
keep this [ __ ] guy out
the backyard looks like the pacific
northwest now
it's a [ __ ] scene [ __ ] humboldt
county back she's gonna be pissed we
talked about this
oh man um
that being said this was from clayton
new member here do you or any family
members have a burnout car or home
appliance in the yard
burnout car holy [ __ ]
we had a washing machine baby
really no but there could have been
our one house that we lived in was down
there it was
up the hill from a junkyard
not good could you see it oh yeah it's
always bad when you say up the hill
yeah we were up the hill now we are up
the hill up the hill
anything around the hill ain't good
unless you're in the [ __ ] beverly
hills
live right down the hill there oh does
he lives down a hill huh you know what
my stepdad says up the road a piece
i'm going up because i'm going up the
road a piece
what is this highway to heaven i don't
know dude traveling down there up the
road a piece
i'm like all right man whatever you say
dude what the [ __ ] yeah he's he's got
he's full of [ __ ] hillbilly
blue collar idioms man yeah
right up the hill from the from the
junkyard it'd be i think it'd be worse
if you were down the hill you'd get the
rust run off and stuff when it rained
get all the [ __ ]
water looks like orange juice yeah lead
painting [ __ ] coming down
that ain't good no it was it was all
right
a couple of times i think some people
were in there poking around and they
came up the hill
looking for trouble down the hill people
got three eyes and [ __ ]
i come up looking at the uphill people
yeah no
but just a [ __ ] old washing machine
just sitting there
no we had a couple of cars that were
like i had my car was in my mom's
driveway for the longest time to montego
for you you can depending on how your
house is set up you can get away with
that like if nobody can see your house
well we're in the cul-de-sac so it's not
a lot of people it was pulled up kind of
yeah
your house i mean you need to be
separated oh yeah of course but then
when you're like that there's usually
more cars like my one neighbor has like
nine cars i don't know what those cars
are what they're doing
it's like none of them work there's one
working headlight within three cars
yeah i don't know we're gonna re that's
like it's always like a shitty old like
not like one of the good mustangs but
like in the 80s when they made them real
cheesy
oh it's like what are you doing yeah
they think that's the thing they think
oh i'm going to get this car and i'm
going to get the [ __ ]
glory days to get the motor fixed yeah
but they know you don't do it right they
don't do it right and then someone comes
along
i got this 82 whatever it's a great deal
700 bucks i got to take it
the bucket of bolts is what you got hit
the bricks it's like my pool right now
it's up on cinders
someone stole the gaps off your pool
pool ain't running oh that being said
there's a [ __ ] in my neighborhood now
there's this guy fixing this expedition
and it's up on blocks he's got the
wheels off it
in the street up on block it's like what
are you doing are you new here
we don't do this around here car
maintenance is designated to your
garage your driveway or if you're in the
city
pulled off to the side in a parking spot
he's an alternate side parking [ __ ]
no wheels
on this thing for like a week and a half
now wait you're talking about up in the
heights you're down by your mom
up in the heights oh man yeah i'm like
how are you moving this thing for
when the street sweeper goes
give me a minute i gotta get the wheels
back velcro
um since this was we were talking about
finances before
uh this is from eric hey guys still
haven't had one read yet have you ever
had to split a transaction
between two different methods of payment
because you only had so much on one card
i don't think i've ever had to
do it i've
my old grocery store uh the one that i
lived in before what i go to before i
just moved last year
but for some i don't know what the hell
what [ __ ]
cia processing credit card machine they
had
but whatever you had in your account
that's exactly what they would take out
it wouldn't get declined
so if i was buying thirty six dollars
worth of [ __ ] i only had twenty dollars
on my card
it would take to twenty one go you owe
sixteen oh that is
garbage yeah so you can't even you can't
even lie be like i was traveling today
they might have shut it down
they just took whatever cash you had so
you look like a real [ __ ] bizarre
what is that sonny delight bank that's
[ __ ] strange
it was whatever it wasn't the bank it
was the [ __ ] processing
it can't be legal they know what you got
they know right away and i'm like oh no
i'm like you still owe 11.50 i'm like
you just processed it like you only had
22 in there i'm like you
how [ __ ] you know what i got who you've
been talking to
you've been talking to regis i got
touchdown bank over here td
all right run it again you've never done
the move uh
cash and the rest on the card sure 100
i've done that
at like a restaurant maybe if we're like
hey take if it's like a big bill
you know what i mean if it's like if
there's a bunch of people out and like
half the people got cash have to people
got a card and it's like oh here's
say the bill's like 400 i'm making a
bonus say the bill's 400. you're like
here take 200 off and then put the rest
on the card
screw the waiter with that though
because then people don't
aren't thinking no you all i mean come
on i'm a [ __ ] gentleman i always tip
of course gentlemen touches yourself um
yeah but i don't think i've ever had to
[ __ ] done it at a 7-eleven
jewel oscar dominic's all over the city
of chicago that was the
move for what are you buying anything
you got [ __ ]
30 bucks in your bank account you got 60
bucks cash you got to get a case of beer
bottle of vanity booze he's talking
about
yeah i would still split it into two
char i've done that when i wasn't sure
how much i had so i go like
oh i'll take this and then i'm like if i
knew i had 50 bucks
and then that came to 40 you know that
came to 40.
and i go oh i also get this for eight
bucks like afterwards
have you ever been in a line with hedge
my bet so i don't get [ __ ] declining
like i got egg on my face
true have you ever been in a line with
your girlfriend and be like i'll get
this and you get that
and the petulias are in line together
making different transactions
oh my buddy was the king of that yeah i
was like i'll get i'll get these three
things you get the pizza
i hate that [ __ ] i put it all together i
put i don't put it all together yeah
it's nuts to me
yeah put it all together and she's
paying all right
she got that probably over at the super
ball machine who's gonna call it
he's got some scratchers uh
one time she i was she came here uh
to visit one time and remember those
days when she would come for like two
weeks
i would check out and i'd have to like
save all of my money up to [ __ ]
to like five take a couple of days off
of work you missed that i was like yeah
i do
yeah whatever um yes you can your
comment on my wife that's my wife now
you would get him to
hear that nadine she watches she listens
love you buddy
happy birthday you would get him happy
birthday happy birthday to the
so uh first of all i posted a picture it
was like hey happy birthday to my wife
and everybody
was like couldn't have been more kind of
like thank you so much for the foreign
investor
for helping the podcast it was like the
sweetest thing ever
a lot of people called me ugly whatever
[Laughter]
joke's on you suckers i got a hot ass
wife at least for now
now i remember in between those trips
what you're referring to is
she'd be here you tripped the lights
fantastic for a couple of weeks
i would be hemmed up yeah and trying to
[ __ ] spin plates when she got it
next time to show the show that should
have brought a good time
yeah well i was used to living you know
we would just do shows every [ __ ]
night in the village
and just drinking for free or cheap
there at the village lantern
[ __ ] dollar slices maybe a cab ride
maybe if you were all banged up yeah if
you're all banged up and i was going to
fall asleep on the subway like i used i
used to sleep on the subway
heavy bite dude just wait guys dude i
lived all the way up town i'd wake up
like out at the airport i should have
been murdered 100 times yeah the one
time
i count i slept like nine hours on the
subway i got like i don't even do that
in my apartment this is just a bit
now and the coffee is great
um but the one the one time i saw i was
like
and i would like i got it that's an ego
thing too for i got i got it i got it i
got it meanwhile she got [ __ ] more
money i got nothing
especially with a new girl yes european
too
i got to impress her so i'm like i got
it i got it and the one time we were at
this dude you don't got it
i don't have it we're at this deli and
uh
deli really pulled out all the stuff no
we were getting like t-bone check out mr
romance over here
oh i know that move no we'll go
somewhere authentic yeah that's how you
spin that yeah
for real new york this is real new york
pumpkin donuts
[ __ ] burger king i heard a king lives
around here actually
is he really the king of aldi burgers in
america
no you are nothing on it
it was good okay um
but i remember i was like all right it
was and those
so you now it's the weekend charges are
coming you don't know what's hitting
what's in there
because that's a fake number that's like
being in the desert and seeing [ __ ] a
waterfall that's all
that's a facade that whatever number's
reflected on news on a sunday
ain't the real number that ain't the
real field
add the windshield to that thing daddy
no it's getting cold out
you better put your hat and gloves on
because monday's gonna be a [ __ ]
blizzard
so i knew i was hemmed up and i'm like
all right oh my god i got it and
i worked i'm thinking i'm being sly and
i check i pull out the td app and i
[ __ ] check that
and i remember had 52 bucks in or
something
um so i bought that was we were just
getting like a drink or whatever at the
at the deli and we were like going
somewhere
and the next purchase was like 38 i
don't know about you but that cranberry
juice really filled me up
[Laughter]
germans eat three meals a day we only do
one over here
hmm nice filling coconut water well i
guess i'm going to head in
[Laughter]
they say we mostly come back to the
place it's 2 pm
getting sleepy it must be the jet lag
you didn't go anywhere
no [ __ ] dude 38 beans so the next thing
was like 38 beans and i'm like
oh god i'm like i'm gonna be left with
like [ __ ]
11 bucks or something like i got it i
got and she goes she literally goes what
are you doing you don't have it
and i'm like yeah i'm like what are you
talking about she's like i saw your
[ __ ] bank statement when you
she goes when you check your account at
the deli she's like you got eight bucks
the jig's over i'm not
clearly not with you for the money bozo
man embarrassed the rest of the trip was
on her
what also was tough was she would come
here and not have uber and lyft
because you know it's like oh i'll put
you in a tight spot
but it's being a touch so now i'm taking
these 40 ubers everywhere so i'd have to
put her
card in my in my uber account
i'd be sitting somewhere on like third
avenue like typing her credit card
number
here for nadine your big head gets in
the car
yeah that's me holy [ __ ] that's trash
yeah it's tough tough dude i did that
same move
i did it this weekend easier on you
right
lyft was doing a promo and i just gotten
a new car a new card so i resigned up
and changed my name
so every time i get in a car they'd be
like for jerry i'd be like yeah
man talk about trying to scam the system
the talented mr mcmullen
[Laughter]
rip off the mustache all right oh man we
got a [ __ ] barn burner here today
folks this is from braxton ever been to
an uncle cracker concert
no but he's got that one hit i like
suspect that guy from
jump street what's that hit he's got
it's not sweet home alabama that's which
that kid rocks on that's like that's he
stunk so bad that he ruined kid rock
that's how
bad he was he brought this bozo down
with him nah he was all right
i he had that one song it was like this
it was like the slow song it was like a
ballad kind of follow me
follow me no there was something else
too we had some a little
something with a little more dirt on it
drifted away i don't know
it was all right i think you're thinking
of the everlast song
what it's like no i'm not uncle cracker
didn't have any deep songs
you were too old at this point uh-uh i'm
probably the same age as he is
uncle crackers 45 look him up probably
52.
he's older probably yeah um whatever
they make pretty decent trash music have
you been to an uncle cracker check
no we would have known by that no my
stepdad went to a kid rock concert like
a few times yeah a few years ago
your stepdad yeah a few years ago like
recent jesus i think it was somebody's
like oh you got these things like i'll
go and i'm like
you what what big ball with the boss
that's a hot track oh dude i was in like
7th grade when that dropped
good [ __ ] night
that wasn't my first like that was like
how you learned to mosh my name is
kippy can you do the can you do the
josie verse you still got it in the
chamber
i started i probably can my name's j-o-e
to the c
ho no i can't call me josie got more
game than galico come on dawg no
no for some reason that didn't stick it
must have not been the radio version i
didn't have the album
i was more of a clean edit kind of guy
mother didn't like curses
trash uncle cracker nah no
i'll stand by it whatever barrel now
we're talking crap
that's got to be something on the road
we got to go to a crap my dad got bad
milka cracker balor one time
who orders milk at cracker barrel my dad
likes milk with breakfast i too
enjoy breakfast i didn't know they did i
didn't know it was a breakfast
establishment oh it's one of their
specialties kevin come on
you're back there stop at the country
store on your way out um
that kid rock song where he took sweet
home alabama that's a pretty good
you're nuts that's a pretty good lick
that's a pretty good lick ah it's so
lame taking another song i hate that
oh yeah i'm sorry sunny day sunny day
original material that's the difference
between you and kimmy kimmy's an
american badass foley yeah
my name is
shout out to kid rock i don't know i
don't align with all his political
stances but
here's something pretty garbage you know
what he did when he he started a beer
company this is
this was 15 years ago i might say
anything about the man no i know but
this is what i really
mean he started a beer company and would
only hire
employees that lost their job at the car
factories
uh i was like that was [ __ ] that's
really cool detroit the beer stinks
tastes like motorcycles these [ __ ]
idiots don't know their way around an
ipa
hey bozo that ain't a carburetor i'm
joking i don't i've never had it but
did you ever make a music video when you
were a kid with your friends
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dead the rights
oh yeah dude man that is
[ __ ] trash
we tried to film the 18b you made one
when you were 38 dude what are you
talking about
you had your mom in yours what as a
voiceover
i was [ __ ] i was 12 with a camcorder
[Laughter]
bingo toby i know you did no but i did
choreograph
a dance with a friend to an nsync song
when it first dropped
that literally started literally started
with
us bursting out of a closet
talk about foreshadowing
ironically you're in one man i like it i
this i don't know if i ever i don't know
if this is
on the board we did one of those things
on the we made one on the boardwalk me
and my boy pat to like the men in black
song remember
when that meant a black song dropped
that was [ __ ] now here comes the man
in black
no the other men in blacks amen
i didn't know it was a song from one or
two ah
but we made one that was like on the
boardwalk and it was just like
there was like a dinosaur float behind
it was a green
screen that was like the only package we
had it was the 90s
so we were like we were like at the
coliseum
and then like in jurassic park we were
just putting us in front of a green
oh you had a professionally made i don't
know
what he called a guy a professional
he wasn't spielberg
where'd you go where'd you go usc huh
i'm a filmmaker you look more like a
tish drama kind of guy here
i do boardwalk green screen and snuff
films
that's working on my thesis fat kid in
front of a dinosaur
oh yeah it was like do you know the man
and like we were like
damn we were probably eight or something
ten
dancing and like the only graphics he
had was like the stock footage on
you know microsoft word or what i was
like oh clip art
it was a bad thing any [ __ ] in there
man that is [ __ ] trash
i thought i literally thought i was
shooting like it was like i thought i
was shooting
something that was going to be i'm like
wait till on tv get a load
gets a load of this i'm going to be on
trl in [ __ ]
no time
we're back on trl with one of the most
amazing artists
of a generation he was discovered on the
wildwood
new jersey boardwalk
dude for a long time standing in the
crowd in times square outside of trl
might have been the trashiest thing you
could have
that and the people still were doing it
like for like good day america with a
sign like hey it's johnny's birthday
wish him and then [ __ ] al roker hey
happy birthday to you
if i ever looked up and i i know my
mother has tried to do it
really she just couldn't get close yeah
her and the girls came up here a few
years ago
oh doing all that doing all that dingbat
[ __ ] [ __ ] here there
yeah seraphina the eminem store well you
know all that stuff
man if i ever flicked on the news trying
to catch up on the world's events
i saw my [ __ ] mom back there waving
would not change the locks i
my mom does the they come up they used
to come up once a year
they bring like the not the nieces so it
would be the nieces
kids like the second generation uh
girls they go to like see the rockettes
and stuff like that but then
they would always go to that diner that
has the broadway singers
you should see them they're great they
they're all broadway stars they're just
like haven't been discovered yet you
know kind of like you with your
comedy career whatever oh they're great
until they forget the mayo
yeah hey liza
enough with the jazz hands where's my
side of fries
i need a chipotle ranch over here oh
yeah oh
damn holy shnikey trash
very very trash this is i mean
the question's pretty good the name i
don't think we've said it yet
uh this is this question comes from i
smell a bernie
i mean come on dude that is a [ __ ]
home run of a name
i smell a bernie and it's the small eye
like apple
do you remember when i popped in here
right in the winter i just had a smoke
that sticks on fat guys worse i don't
know more surface area
yeah and the cold's tough yeah man
coming in after ripping one on a cold
night trying to [ __ ] blend back into
a [ __ ] christmas party
[ __ ] crab puff in your mouth
[Laughter]
um this is from iu where are you i smell
it bernie
uh this just says collection of shitty
bicycles that don't work under the deck
question mark
question of shitty bites because you
have a big deck you got a lot of [ __ ]
surface area you can put stuff
on no there's nothing under there just
[ __ ] a couple of raccoons though from
time oh
yeah yeah some groundhogs yeah there's
some there's some
there's some [ __ ] goes down under there
that backyard some [ __ ] happens cause
there's a
there's a thicket of wood back there
that a couple of fox run
and there's some groundhogs and some
other some other animals back there
i don't like it no but there's no bikes
the only thing underneath that
porch is or that deck is uh old
tinfoil bowls that i folded up and slid
under there high school get rid of the
evidence a little bit of crack
um cigarette butts couple
oh yeah down there yeah about 25 years
worth of [ __ ] bernie's in there
and that's it yeah and some bottle caps
yeah we have one we always we had like
la we put we had a low it was a low guy
you know it was maybe a foot or so we
just shoved
[ __ ] went under there for sure a lot of
burnies too put them out and flick them
down
at high school parties well like a
raccoon in a marble wild jacket
he's got he's got the canoe groundhog
wrangler i recently had to [ __ ] with the
little shed we have on the side
of the of the house for the first time
in probably 25 years i gotta go get the
umbrella stands out of there
cobweb city yeah [ __ ]
that's something you hold your breath
the air is colder in there you're like
what the [ __ ]
you walk into the draculas yeah i don't
[ __ ] with that
um did you just pluralize dracula
yeah dracula's his place
oh possessive yeah possessive there you
go
this one this is from jesse have you
ever ordered a sub at subway and told
the clerk to
drag it through the garden which
i like but it's trashy drag it through
the garden
i don't think the wawa employee
appreciated it either yeah
lettuce tomato onions to give it the
whole give it peppers whatever take it
through whatever sticks
yeah i would say give me everything
but i can't get everything at subway a
couple of weird things in there i don't
know what they are
i used to be a big fan of the chicken
porn there which is
crazy they do i tell you what they did a
meatball farm in the 90s
the meatball was all right the chicken
they did breaded chicken
for a while and we would have to call me
and my buddy love them we would have to
call subway to be like
you got the bread of chicken and we'd
have to like find we'd call a couple to
go
to oh yeah a couple of fat mouth
breathers coming in for the chickens
you and jonah hill
[Laughter]
yeah i've called a subway that's a bad
luck if you're calling
i don't even know they have a phone
where the [ __ ]
calling a subway is tough you ever try
to get dominoes on the phone jesus
christ
it's like you're calling a [ __ ] cia
safe house like all the menus and you
never get through yeah
i didn't get that i tried to go along
with it all right i feel like they would
answer the phone i mean it's a pizza
place yeah
maybe they would i mean you should you
ever try to get a jiffy lube on the
phone something
you domino's is all online now you can't
get a hold of anybody
okay i didn't know you don't even know
what store you're ordering from
yeah you do no you don't you just go
into the website and [ __ ]
says they pair you up sure they tell you
but it's not the same one you don't know
what's going on
well i'm not gonna give you one in
[ __ ] tallahassee they're gonna give
you the one closest but you gotta figure
it out
and then you gotta call them and then
they don't answer i stand by my joke
whatever yeah um this one is for you
uh so from alex first time question just
joined when eating a snack
example little debbie swiss rolls do you
pick the chocolate off the wrap or the
cardboard and eat it
what a great question i can't force you
know i can't really see you throwing out
anything with chocolate still on
no of course not i thought i i
interpreted the question
as do i do it for sport not out of
necessity like if it sticks you ever
open up a crimp it or a cupcake
and it sticks to the top that was yep
that back in the day ruined my life
yeah i liked it though you go in on it
yeah you [ __ ]
jolt little pep in your stuff i would oh
yeah just i'm not leaving anything
yeah you got to take of course if it's
necessity it's not really the way i want
it to go down to be honest with you
there's there's easier ways we could
have done it yeah you could do the hard
way yeah you went with the message the
starburst will jack you up like that
every once in a while you get a
starburst on a hot day trying to get
that out of the wrap
yeah they'll [ __ ] already chewed gum
yeah they'll screw you yeah
um all right this was from jess uh have
you ever seen your dad shoot an animal
with a bb gun
i have we bought a bb gun i think for we
had a groundhog
and it was like my sole mission in
fourth grade to [ __ ] get this thing
he was a big man pajama too
about the size of you this thing would
come out [ __ ] rooting through
everything
a rabbit no uh groundhog oh yeah you
should have groundhog come on they're so
cute
there's a whole [ __ ] great movie
based upon killing a groundhog
which one caddyshack oh yeah that's
right
interesting foreign film
uh yeah my dad we were very weird
kimmy's out the front long
[Laughter]
um we got the red rider bb i got the red
rider bb gun the actual red rider that
was a real thing yeah it was bad that's
not gonna have enough power to kill a
[ __ ]
groundhog no you just scare him away
send him to the neighbors
scare him away and he comes back with
more groundhogs
you gotta finish the job they're
knocking on the door where's the fat one
at
never bring it back i'm doing the men in
black dancing
do you never bring a bb gun to a [ __ ]
gun fight we were just crazy
he was under the deck we rented a house
that was always a tough load we were
always renting houses my father had a
pellet gun for a little while those were
like
those were like the tr you know the the
pellet gun
it was it was the pellet gun was the
trike to a quad
do you remember the trike the three
wheeled that those things pellet guns
and trikes were illegal in the 90s when
that's coming up
when somebody finally had a pellet and
you look like that one
it's like a hollow point yeah yeah that
thing didn't [ __ ] around take a bike
tire right off
um we had to shoot at some varmints my
dad
would [ __ ] barmets whatever like
groundhogs that's a varmint
or whatever i didn't know you were in
the biz
he would have to scare a couple of
things away from the from the dog
because we had a german shepherd at the
time who was an outside dog
and she had a little house back there
yeah well that's what i thought that's
what the
german shepherd can't handle himself
with a [ __ ] critter if the dog was
back there barking and yelling he'd go
up under
he'd go up onto the top deck so he's
laying on the roof
he's got a scope out
henry put your cigarette down he's going
to make us
tell me to tell my wife take this shot
he's breathing heavy it's getting hairy
it's getting hairy
i got more i got three more coming and
three clicks out
gotta make we're gonna make a move make
a move now it's like the beginning of
shooter
dead dad they're right behind us
[Laughter]
what's that red dot on your head oh [ __ ]
you got a red daughter in your head
foley's dad's like yeah check out this
photo of my girl back home it's like
yeah it's my mom
i got this fine piece of ass back home
yeah she's making dinner dad
shout out to the foleys i love you i'm
waiting on my invite once you get the
[ __ ] once you get new spark plugs in
the pool or whatever
i'm gonna come down with the broad oh
[ __ ] yo
so remember what you guys are you guys
told me about a whirlpool in the
aboveground pool
we were at when all my homies were in
town for the service
uh we went to the pool at their hotel
and my one buddy goes you think we get
there's like eight of us it's like i
think we get a whirlpool going and my
buddy pops out of the water and goes
whirlpool
we need about eight more hands and pull
this side
knowing yeah knowing how many people
it's gonna take to make a whirlpool
getting eight more people or two foleys
try to do the same thing at a labor day
party back in 85
tore my rotator cuff
top this size you're gonna need more
hands
that's the set of keys in two seconds um
all right let's uh let's fire through
let's do two or three more here um
of course this is from jonah have you
ever stolen one of those huge rolls of
toilet paper at a public restroom to use
it at home
now i gotta say i think about it every
that's the garbage in me i still look
and go i could use that at the house
but then what are you gonna do wait yeah
what are you gonna chain it to the wall
like how are you gonna hook it up well
you know what i've realized that i've
been doing
lately is i'm not gonna like whatever
this is i feel like i
take the toilet paper off off the roll
and i undo it like that and then when
i'm done i put it back on the thing
i don't know why so i could see having
that big thing in my hand and just
setting it on the side
like captain america's shield uh
yeah i mean go for it i don't it's a
there's a lady
i knew people that stole regular rolls
from work all the time
yeah yeah i mean i know restaurant jobs
and [ __ ] yeah there's a woman that goes
in there she was
before the pandemic she would go into
the uh cafe
in my neighborhood every week or every
couple of days and steal all
because they had like a top shelf like a
hundred rolls or whatever
she would go old lady would go in and
steal and just fill up her purse
and they were they would catch her every
time she get off of me and leave and
then come in [ __ ] three days later
really it was like a scene every time
they were like marie get out of there
we know it's you they'd be like banging
on the door yeah
it's like she was just like that's like
one of those people that have just been
in new york too long and she's just like
this crazy old lady who's just doesn't
give up just doesn't know or she's like
that's right i ain't got to steal the
nude she's probably a [ __ ]
millionaire too
pour like soup on your [ __ ] if you
were saying yeah or things pour hot
water on you
get you something yeah exactly yeah
yikes
um all right this is from dylan
um trash oh
wow i don't even think i saw this one
all right this is from dylan
first time asking ever fooled around
with a step sibling or parents
significant other's kid mom's boyfriend
caught me with his daughter when we were
like 15 and went and got my mom
talk about an awkward morning talk about
talk about this what talk about the
videos i watch online
now things are getting steamy as long as
you got her hands stuck in the garbage
disposal i'm listening
do you speak russian wait a minute
give me that question again slowly i
just want to hear
the the the the the sub
whatever yeah this is from dylan ever
fooled
around ever fooled around with a
step-sibling sibling or parent
significant others kids or mom's
boyfriend's daughter or
son so almost step sibling
mom's boyfriend caught me with his
daughter when we were like 15 and went
and got my mom
talk about an awkward morning my mom's
boyfriend
yeah caught me with his dog which
there's technically
that's nothing it's not they're just
strangers i ain't got nothing wrong with
that
small town as long as everybody's
underage or over age
et cetera et cetera everybody's
consenting yes of course
yeah i don't know why you went that way
with it i'm just saying yeah of course i
mean i just thought that was implied
well not these days and i was not with
our listeners
uh yeah i you know
it's not something i would dabble in did
you ever have any kind of
were there were there ever any females
on that side of the family
no step mom situation i had a stepmom
yeah right
yeah yeah but she didn't have any kids
of her own though with my dad
yeah i don't think my brother would like
me taking a run at him
shout out to mike it doesn't count get
over here
tough prank mikey uh yeah no no we never
had any extended
there was never no brady bunch moment of
family's
okay just step mom step dad yeah that's
uh i mean
kids will be kids but that's that's all
but i'm mom's boyfriend
i wonder if the steps everyone gets all
over because you're probably in the same
house at certain points
they continue to stay together though
because he said it was my mom's
boyfriend
i think at the time at the time i don't
[ __ ] let me ask you this
let's say you were that dad and you
were involved with this woman whose son
was hooking up with your daughter sure
all
you know both teenagers everything above
board everything above board
welcome to ayg after dark folks
would you con
like you caught them you know coitus
sure or heavy petting either way
i'm listening continue do you continue
with the relationship depends on you
know the size of the cans the mom has
i'm sorry gladys your son's got too much
game
yeah gotta get out of here i mean
honestly could you would you be able to
deal with that knowing that like if
you know you guys move in together
there's a good possibility
spread off spraying with the hose get
out of here uh
i don't know it would have to depend how
serious i am with the mom it would have
to depend you know a lot of factors i
can't just make a
you know i don't know that seems seems
like a no-brainer
i'm also not letting the [ __ ] you
know my daughter ruin a good piece of
ass for me
you know what i mean this mom sounds
like she probably looks pretty good on
the back of a motorcycle too by the way
and in this fantasy i got a harley
you're saying i can be whoever i want in
this situation you know if it's honest
with a ponytail
what color rubber band you want um all
right
let's do two more then we'll get out of
here um this is from sassy pants do you
avoid going to the mailbox
just to let the mail pile up if so how
long until it's garbage
100 buddy you could i you could cram or
pull the kramer weld mine shut
bricks in there i don't want nothing i
want it no i don't want it
i don't want it i don't i'll find out i
know when they shut it off i'll realize
i gotta pay it okay
they would email me don't stop me even
that stop emailing me spectrum cable
wastes so much money on these bills they
send me
crazy i know it's nuts and i ain't even
paying them
listen don't me this you don't need to
mail me more [ __ ] i know it's new
okay i i wait at least like a week or
two and i just got a text
saying hey we're gonna [ __ ] shut you
down what
that time my at home oh i thought you
meant your mailbox
no they can they can [ __ ] my wife
took care of my wife goes
i'm taken i go yeah you go now she just
brings up the mail out of she's like oh
these 17 things are for you i'm like
yeah i'm not just
rip them up throw them in right all i
get is [ __ ] credit card
offers that i can't afford and i'm not
going to get qualified for anyway
magazine in a boy's life the highlights
i wouldn't mind that
i would do a what a boy's life sure
whatever just
get a monthly magazine or a weekly
magazine be excited
something in the mail you know who's
getting that
you get any publications delivered to
your residence
sorry what was the question i was still
reeling from that egregious bomb i just
had what was up
do you i blacked it out still i'm
still in the denial phase of grief on
that one we've done a lot of that today
yeah we've breezed over a couple of
things a couple of which i think is a
gentlemanly thing to do
yeah it's been a while since we've seen
each other we're not [ __ ] really at
each other's throat
yeah do you get any publications at your
house no way
no huh yeah i don't get [ __ ]
okay um my bank still thinks i live in
chicago
that's good so does mine i think no they
know i'm here
they got me so does my wife and kid huh
all right uh this will be the last one
and we gotta wrap it up
uh this is from greg first time asking
have you ever thrown
or attended a themed watch party for
example this past sunday a friend of
mine threw a uh
mayor of east town watch party with
philly cheesesteaks rolling rock beers
and other philly-centric food or drinks
let me tell you something first of all
that sounds like a good time though it's
just taking a couple of a couple of
ponies
but here's the thing i've lived in the
philadelphia area my entire life
i don't who the [ __ ] drinking rolling
rock my dad
shout out to latrobe what yeah dude
13.99 for a 30 rack
yeah rolling rock's huge hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa relax
i don't know anybody in the philadelphia
area that drinks rolling rocks yeah a
lot of people
really yeah it's a it's a pennsylvania
beer i'm aware of that
okay but i don't know i'm not saying
it's the best one
i'm a yingling man i was surprised when
i saw on the show that they were pushing
the rolling rocks
yeah not yinglings you know the face
[Music]
i'm sure it is yeah i've never been to a
watch party
i remember like game of thrones
people would [ __ ] do that [ __ ] or
[ __ ] walter or
uh breaking bad people would do i shaved
my head yeah
uh nope that's garbagio yeah that's i
mean
i guess if you're having fun with it in
the sense of that you're not dressing up
like that's like more of like hey we're
gonna have food
and beers that's a i'm relatively okay
with that
hey come over for the thing we're gonna
have cheesesteaks
sure but you're not [ __ ] putting a
philly you're not dressing up like the
fanatic yeah you're not dressing up like
a like a like a cop
walker whatever the [ __ ] they are yeah
yeah the outfits are
yeah no bueno any theme party like that
is garbage
yeah even when people have like a
costume party when it's not halloween
i've done a murder mystery oh my god
you have yeah where uh
recently no
no uh it was probably over a decade ago
you were single at the time oh my god
well in my defense it really it was
kevin beating
alone in the foyer it was if i'm at this
party they're solving a murder and they
got a suicide on their ass
guys toby hung himself in the bathroom
too
uh no it was uh we got to wrap this up
it was uh
that's it folks thanks for tuning in
everybody i'm still cool guy kippy huh
what the [ __ ] it's not like i organized
it it was
early 20s college maybe
it was probably still in college it's
even worse
no so it was a friend a friend you know
very well
mm-hmm him and his friends put it on
and it literally nobody played the game
it everybody it just ended up a [ __ ]
party with like 100 people that's all it
ended up
there was like four people who were like
hey i
i have this and people like get out like
once the [ __ ] yayo started flying
everybody was like
hey [ __ ] hey sherlock hit the [ __ ]
bricks
trying to play beer pong over here and
do some nose beers
[Laughter]
man yeah yeah yeah
i don't know yeah i'm sorry i'm being
honest did you have did you have an
outfit
on do you have like suspenders and like
a sherlock holmes hat on
did you no
it wasn't that locked the doors no one
leaves
someone fought this has been a bit he's
been pushing he's been writing that joke
for [ __ ] 18 years
um and finally what was it sherlock
holmes but the fart edition
it was a sketch idea i had for uh
fartlock
shitlock home shitlock
he would go to like you know like real
high falutin like parties and stuff like
that
and if somebody farted he would figure
out who it was so they could all
ridicule them for being
uncouth yeah lock the doors no one
leaves someone farted
that's it folks
it's elementary my dear watson actually
said it was the beans
yeah double down on it i mean the
[ __ ] the punchline's stuck
you thought the tag was gonna sorry i
was gonna get the kid over here no
no he's [ __ ] tuned out the guy's in
grief mode over here
gang that's the episode we [ __ ] love
you guys we love our family episodes
yeah
um make sure you get those tickets for
uh
for ac june 18th a couple of tickets
left
make sure you do it in indianapolis show
the [ __ ] up let's go yeah come on
chicago sell out for our fourth show
yeah check it out links are in the
description
check it out also while we're at it we
have [ __ ]
baltimore's on sale stress factory in
new jersey is on
sale uh providence rhode island's on
sale boston
boston on sale and that's going to
[ __ ] sell out that's boston
those tickets are already [ __ ] moving
and that's not until late august so
get those [ __ ] tickets we're going to
be everywhere this summer see you today
it's going to be a good summer
oh peace